and thanks to the organizers for the
opportunity to speak
so i will talk about constraint
optimization on romanian manifolds
um and just let me start with briefly
recalling why we are interested in
reminding optimization we've seen some
nice applications and use cases earlier
today
but one other way to motivate rimanian
optimization is that in many
applications especially if we think
about
machine learning we encounter
data with an explicit or implicit
non-euclidean structure
so we can think of data like graphs
strings or matrices
and in such cases it can be beneficial
to
represent the data in a space that
naturally aligns with its geometry and
then if we want to perform an
optimization or machine learning task to
adapt those algorithmic tools to the
specific
space
and in the optimization context
one very interesting
aspect that we can make use of is
geodesic
convexity
so especially for for matrix value
problems some of which we saw earlier
today
those
and that are non-convex in euclidean
space we can actually with the right
choice of metric turn those into convex
problems on a suitable romanian manifold
and that then benefits us when we want
to
perform an optimization task
so the examples that we will see in this
talk
are mostly for
metrics valued problems so
where we have to optimize a metrics
valued function
and for such problems we can use tools
from euclidean optimization
where
the class of matrices that we are
working with typically enders as a
constraint so maybe we are optimizing
a subject to a orthogonality constraint
or we have some constraints on the rank
for instance
but we could also use tools from
romanian optimization
where we rephrase the problem on a
suitable manifold which encodes
that specific constraint so for instance
for a positive definiteness constraint
that would be the manifold of positive
definite matrices
so and then in the euclidean setting we
can use draws from
unconstrained optimization
and that has received a lot of interest
and there are lots of classical
algorithms that have been explored in
those settings
but if we look at some specific
applications and problems that we might
want to solve with such techniques then
we see that oftentimes there are
actually additional constraints that we
would have to handle so
in addition to the sort of basic
constraint which tells us which manifold
to work on we might have interval
constraints or
equality or inequality constraints which
are not directly
being handled by the unconstrained
optimization
methods so in those settings we would
need
it would be nice to have constraint
optimization methods that can directly
handle such additional constraints
and before we talk about such methods um
i just want to briefly recall geodesic
connectivity i know referred a lot of
that um
already uh earlier but i just want to
define it so if we have a
function defined on a romanian manifold
m
then we say that it is geodesically
convex if it fulfills essentially the
same usual complexity condition
that we use in euclidean space but now
with respect to a geodesic on that
manifold
and then the optimization context just
as in the euclidean setting
this gives us the guarantee that we have
a unique global optimum
um so for classical
optimization algorithms such as romanian
gradient descent we know that from any
feasible initializations those
algorithms will converge to that global
optimum meaning that we can get nice
global convergence guarantees
and oftentimes this also helps us to
quantify the rate of convergence so
gives us
a chance at deriving non-asymptotic
convergence guarantees
and we already said in the in the
metrics
context
it's especially interesting to look at
problems which are non-convex and
euclidean setting but where this
reformulation on a romanian manifold
gives us geodesic complexity
and some examples for that are for
instance the computation of
riemannian centroids on the manifold of
positive definite matrices so that's a
special instance of the karcher mean
problem also the computation of grass
complete constants that we've heard
about earlier or the computation of
generalized eigenvalues for instance
so in this talk
as i said we will focus on constraint
optimization so just to
clarify the
class of problems that we're looking at
so we have a function defined on a
romanian manifold which we assume to be
smooth but not necessarily
geodesically combat so we will see that
some of the results also apply to
geodesically non-convex functions
and we require that the minimum of the
function that we're trying to compute
lies in a compact and geodesically
convex subset of the manifold which we
will denote as crypt x
and our goal is to efficiently compute a
solution to this problem
and for the remainder of the talk um
this is what we what we're going to talk
about so we will
introduce an
algorithm on the money manifolds which
can directly handle constraints
and we will also look um at the
convergence at what convergence
guarantees we can get for that algorithm
um and besides sort of a general
analysis also look at some
um specific settings um especially
stochastic and finite some settings
which are important for
machine learning applications
and we will talk about
what are the bottlenecks if we want to
make this algorithm practical so if you
want to
actually implement it and use it in
practice and also look at one
simple application that shows us how to
make this algorithm practical on one
specific example
and everything that i'm going to talk
about is trying to work with sofitsra at
mit and based on the
two papers in the footnote
okay so
to get a general idea how we could
define
an algorithm on romanian manifolds which
can directly handle constraints we can
look at what has been done in the
euclidean setting
of course such a basic problem is
constraint optimization is very well
studied in the euclidean setting
and in the literature we see that there
are essentially two classes of
algorithms that are
that are popular that are being used
projected gradient methods and also
projection free methods
protected gradient methods
are essentially extensions of gradient
descent style methods to the constraint
setting
so the basic idea here is that if an
iteration k we are at a point
x k
then
we evaluate the gradient to find a
feasible descent direction and then
perform a standard gradient descent
update
and this of course doesn't take the
constraints into account which means
that this update update might carry us
out of the feasible region here shown in
in blue
and in that case we have to project back
onto the feasible regions so we have to
compute
construct some projection and depending
on the geometry of our
constraint set of the feasible region
this might be
easy to do or this might be expensive
in cases where it is expensive
it's interesting to use a projection
free method which can directly handle
constraints
and here the most probably most popular
method is the frank wolf algorithm
which works as follows so again in
iteration k we're at a point x k
we evaluate the gradient to find the
feasible descent direction
and then
we call a subroutine
which which we call the linear oracle
and this separating will compute a point
in the feasible descent direction which
just fulfills the constraints so in our
example here
that point set k which is returned from
the linear oracle life on the boundary
of the feasible region and then we
linearly interpolate
between our current iterate and that
point set k
and then step along that line with a
certain step size s k which is typically
chosen to be something like 1 over k
and then if we
assume
that our feasible region is uh convex
then any point along that line will be
in the feasible region meaning that we
will never step out of the feasible
region and therefore also don't have to
worry about projecting back onto it
and then
again depending on the specific setting
of the problem
it might be difficult
or it might be easy to compute that
the solution of the subroutine so in
practice one what one usually does is to
compare um the cost of computing those
projections with the cost of solving the
linear oracle and then based on that
decide what what might be
the best type of algorithm to use
okay so that was for the euclidean
setting um the romanian gradient descent
is the gradient descent algorithm is
very well studied on romanian manifolds
so
that extension to
projected gradient methods which handle
constraints only indirectly is sort of
easy to do but it turns out that on
manifolds it can be difficult to compute
those additional projections
so it's worth looking into
extending those projection-free
methods to rimanian manifolds as well
and to define such an algorithm
we essentially have to look at two
key components of the algorithm so which
is of course the linear oracle
and then the way we construct the update
step
so
first thing to note is that of course
instead of the euclidean gradient we now
evaluate the riemann gradient and then
for this interpolation step
we are now
constructing a geodesic on the
respective manifold
with a starting point being our current
iterate the endpoint being the
point set k that is returned from the
linear oracle and then the speed of the
geodesic will be at the gradient at the
the current iterate
and that allows us to write down a
riemannian equivalent
of the euclidean
framework algorithm
and then what what can we say about the
sort of channel con convergence
um we can adapt the proof techniques
that we have
for the euclidean frank wolf algorithm
two remaining manifolds and then i'm
sure that that algorithm converges at a
sublinear rate so this means
that after k iterations we are on the
order of one over k close
uh to the optimum if we are if we have a
geodesically convex
objective then that would be the global
optimum if we have a geodesically
non-convex function that's of course
only only a local optimum
and then to put that convergence rate
into a perspective so that recovers um
an iteration complexity comparable to to
what we know for the euclidean fringe
wolf method and that's also comparable
to the rates that we get
for the romanian gradient descent in the
general case
so like in the euclidean setting
we could think of this as okay we need
about the same number of iterations to
to reach a certain accuracy and then we
can look at the cost of each iteration
so
if we can solve the romanian linear
oracle very efficiently then that would
turn this into a practical algorithm
but before we
focus on on this problem of solving the
um reminder linear oracle let's look at
some um special cases and what we can
say about the
um the performance of the algorithm in
in those settings
so if we have
a geodesically
a strongly geodesically convex objective
meaning that we fulfilled this condition
so the first part of this condition is
just the usual
is equivalent to the definition of
geodesic convexity that we saw earlier
just now written with respect to the
inverse exponential map and not with
respect to geodesics and then we have
this additional term here which
characterizes the the strong convexity
so if our
objective fulfills this stronger
assumption on convexity and if we know
that the optimum does not lie on the
boundary of the feasible region then we
actually get linear convergence so then
this algorithm is is very fast
in the euclidean setting
there are
this this problem of when uh frink wolf
methods have a fast linear convergence
it has also received a lot of
attention and there are different
assumptions that have been studied under
which such faster rates can be achieved
but to our knowledge on the
um this
this strong convexity assumption does
translate to the romanian setting some
of the other
results that are known in euclidean
settings don't really have or are
difficult to to channelize to romanian
settings
so especially with applications in mind
we might also think about how we can
adapt such algorithms to
specific classes of objective functions
that that we encounter in in
applications
um so the first one are stochastic
settings where we want to optimize a
black box function so the difficulty
here is that we don't have access to the
um
to the underlying structure of the the
function that we want to optimize and
then um finite some settings
um does secure in in many
many different applications so if you
think of empirical risk minimization or
maximum likelihood estimation
there you typically have objective
functions which are
large sums over component functions
so here if you think about computing the
gradient of functions with such a
structure then you have to average over
a sum of
the gradients of all of those component
functions and so if m is very large that
can be computationally expensive and
also introduce a bottleneck
into the algorithm
so so how how can we
deal with those two settings um
for the stochastic setting um here the
difficulty is since we don't have access
to the underlying function we of course
also don't have access directly to the
to the gradient we can only
estimate it
over all the samples that we draw
so our
romanian linear organ will have this
stochastic form
and then here we can again take
inspiration from the euclidean setting
and
look at how these stochastic settings
are dealt with in the euclidean
setting and here what one typically does
is to use a weapons monroe approximation
after the gradient so use a batch
estimate
and the same
we can do in this setting
and then by
carefully
controlling the the batch size
we can keep the the gradient estimation
error in in check and recover
the the sub linear convergence
guarantees that we had earlier in the in
the general deterministic setting
for the finite sum setting um
where we want to control the the cost of
computing the gradient we can
use a different gradient estimation
technique so instead of
in each iteration computing the full
gradient of all of those component
functions
we can just
take a subset of component functions um
and and just we can just recompute the
full gradient every couple of iterations
and then in between
um compute the gradient or averaged only
over a subset of the gradients
um so which significantly reduces uh the
cost and such approaches are called
variance reduced approaches so we can
also adapt those to the riemann setting
and then by carefully controlling the
size of those subsets and after how many
iterations we recompute the gradient
um we can again keep the
estimation error in check
and recover the the global
sub linear convergence rates
and
we have also looked into like a
a recent
improvement of that estimation technique
so this has originally been studied for
the euclidean sgd so stochastic gradient
descent
and there it was shown that it's
actually not necessary to
ever compute the full gradient if you
want a sub-linear convergence rate it's
enough to just iterate um to just switch
between
different
sets of sample sizes one a little bit
larger and then choose smaller
sample sizes in between and that still
recovers
the sublinear convergence rate and
a similar
analysis can be done for the riemann
spring both method again by carefully
trading off these sample sizes
okay so so to to summarize um those
techniques especially in the in the
finite sum setting
allow us to circumvent the computation
of four gradients
i'm significantly speeding up our
methods
we do pay a little bit in the
convergence rate so as i said we we do
recover a global sublinear rate
but it drops from on the order of one
over k to 1 over square root k
this comes from
the the estimation error that we are
making even though
we are trying to to carefully control
that
yeah
so all of them have
right sorry what is it word that's great
for all of these and they're all
the iteration complexity the iteration
complexity is one over square root of k
uh but for rituals because the first one
should be one over k now
so those are oracle complexities
so this is the crosstalk this is the
cost of each iteration and then
iteration complexity means what accuracy
do i reach after how many conversions
so yeah so so this is for the
deterministic one where i compute the
four gradient and then if i use the
gradient estimates this drops to one
over four boxes for all
yeah so it's slightly
slightly less efficient but you'll
actually see that in the numerical
experiments
um the the faster computation of each
iteration um overall wins out and makes
those faster
okay so now let's talk about the
the crucial separating the romanian
linear oracle
so in the in the euclidean setting
one one aspect that has contributed to
um the different growth method being so
so popular is that this subroutine is
convex and relatively easy to to solve
in the romanian setting unfortunately
the separating is non-convex
so we have to think a little bit more
careful about um how to solve that in in
practice
um two sort of ideas that come to mind
on how we might solve this is
um first we could use some numerical
servers and off the shelf method um get
some approximate solution
and then um
hopefully keep this in check to
retain our our sublinear iteration
complexity
or we could look at um special cases and
see if there are better ways of solving
that separating so since that is
non-convex um there's not much hope for
having sort of a channel recip general
recipe for solving that efficiently in
each case but it turns out in special
cases
there are faster ways of solving that
subroutine
so but first for the
if we only solve it approximately
so this condition would mean that we
would have an exact minimizer
for the linear oracle and then if we put
an error term here
we can call this a data approximate
minimizer
and then with an adaption of the
previous convergence analysis
we see that if if delta is
small that doesn't actually hurt us very
much so we retain the
sublinear iteration complexity and then
just have this
small factor entering here which depends
on on delta
so as long as we have a sufficiently
good numerical solver which allows us to
relatively efficiently compute
[Music]
a delta approximate minimizer then that
should work pretty well in practice
uh what we have to keep in mind is that
uh those numerical solvers have to be
called in each iteration of the
algorithm so overall it's um gonna be
still
quite expensive
so it is worth it looking into
smarter ways of solving
the linear oracle
and i want to just give one example
where we can actually
solve it very efficiently in in closed
form
so the example that i want to talk about
is on the manifold of symmetric positive
definite matrices where our script x our
constraint set our interval constraints
so those are here defined with respect
to the uh learning order so recall that
we say
x is uh
larger or equal to l in in left order if
x minus l has only
uh non-negative eigenvalues so that
introduces a partial order relation on
positive definite matrices which allows
us to define interval constraints
and then
this is how the
the linear oracle looks in this case so
here we have just inserted the remaining
gradient and then the inverse of the
exponential map
on that manifold
and some of the problems that we
mentioned earlier
are actually of that form
so including
the romanian centroids the
um a special case of the karcher mean
problem and then also
vassars9 bari centers on the gaussian
density manifold
um so this gaussian density manifolds
also called the divorce manifold as
isomorphic to the manifold of positive
definite matrices
and so therefore we can
phrase this
problem of vasculin body centers also of
that form and that has some interesting
connections to optimal transport and
also sampling so that's something that
also recently has
received quite a bit of attention
um in and in that specific case
we get the following
uh closed form solution
um
in this talk i i cannot go into too many
details about um how to arrive there but
if you're interested it's in the paper
so we get a
a closed-form solution for the
subroutine so we don't have to call um a
numerical solver
in that case we can just implement the
clause from solution which is much more
efficient of course than calling the
numerical solver
and to see how this
then works in in practice let's look at
one specific example
um the
problem of computing romanian centroids
on the manifold of positive definite
matrices
um so the the objective that we have
here
is as follows
so we have a collection of
positive definite matrices ai
which might have
weights associated
and then we want to minimize um
the
the disparity center problem delta r
here is the riemannian metric on that
manifold and we recall what we said
earlier that this is one of the
interesting problems that's non-convex
in the euclidean setting but with this
choice of metric it is geodesically
convex so by using our
frank wolfe methods here we get global
convergence guarantees
and then where do we get the the
constraints from here um so we all know
for real numbers we have the means
inequality we know that the geometric
mean is lower bounded by the harmonic
mean and upper bounded by the arithmetic
mean and this relation also
translates
to matrices
and
fortunately both the harmonic and
arithmetic mean can be computed very
easily in closed form the geometric mean
the geometric matrix mean unfortunately
not since matrix multiplication does not
commute so
as soon as we have more than two
matrices um this cannot be computed in
closed form
anymore hence um
this being a
a good use case for for romanian
optimization
um
and then our algorithm
looks as follows so
we already said we can easily
pre-compute the harmonic and hermetic
mean
and then in each iteration we would
compute the remaining gradient
we have this
separating the linear oracle which we
solve with the clause from solution that
we just saw
and then we construct
our geodesic with a step size which we
again set to like 1 over k
and here are some
results for for different
generated inputs so here we see in blue
the
sort of standard
romanian frank wolf algorithm and then
also here included some of the
stochastic variants that we
that we've seen
so
um notice that that has a finite sum
structure that we discussed earlier so
here we can use these
estimation techniques to
lower the cost of computing the
gradients and then we also see here
that that
in fact translates
to um
to to faster conversions and then we
compare here against some
other um
some other methods riemannian
optimization algorithms in the
literature so those are variants of of
the riemannian gradient descent
algorithm and we we see that we're
pretty competitive uh compared to those
we also see that we
reach a pretty good accuracy with those
methods
we do lose a little bit with the
stochastic methods that work with
gradient estimates
but even with those we're
at a reasonably good accuracy
okay and that's the end of my talk um so
we talked about um frank both methods
for projection free optimization on the
money and manifolds and discuss some
different settings both channel
deterministic settings and also some
stochastic settings that
are a bit more interesting for
applications
and we've seen that those algorithms are
practical
if we can solve the remainder linear or
go efficiently and we've seen
one example or one class of problems
where this is the case we have some
others
in in the paper
and in
future direction i hope to
explore applications of that especially
in machine learning contexts
more and also in general look more
systematically at how we can efficiently
solve the linear oracle for
other metrics manifolds and other
constraint sets
maybe some of the initial examples that
i've shown for for a start
okay
thanks yeah
let's decide here
so this comparison here is
so this is in terms of when you're
talking about accuracy here you you run
all this over in the same number of
iterations or in the same amount of time
for your like algorithms
because you're explaining that before if
if you have the same on the moderator
the accuracy is already theoretically
supposed to be
worse right but then
what matters is the total time it takes
two
oh
yeah so so this is plotted with respect
to the computing time
um
yeah but but then um we did give them a
max number of iterations right i mean
you could you could run it forever right
but you have like some max number of
iterations um after you stop it yeah so
that's maybe not so easy to see here
um but but yeah you do see if you run
everything the
required number of um you know a similar
number of iterations up to some round of
errors you do see that they reach a
similar accuracy yeah
right so like
if you let them run for a particular
number of times yeah
i see
yeah so but this is here just to make it
uh you're not comparable to the
performance processes are shown with
respect to
um the
the uh computing time but i think we
have in the paper also for uh to to just
show it with respect to the number of
iterations
well you know but i think this is the
more interesting right because what you
care about in the end is
how long you run your algorithm not the
number of iterations yeah so yeah
but even then the deterministic ones are
better okay so this is showing if they
run by the same amount of time you get
more actors
yeah that's that's to be expected you
also see that for you know
if you if you use the
um
yeah you use the gradient estimates you
um you have a little error especially if
you if you once you get close to the
to the optimum and the approximation
error of the gradient will introduce an
error right
so so this
this flattening out sort of of the of
the stochastic version uh you also see
another stochastic optimization method
so it's something very typical you see
because once you're close
right the approximation error will
have a significant impact
yeah so so that's that's a very typical
behavior
yeah so typically there you have to if
you use that in practice you have to be
very careful to build in stopping
criteria
right because otherwise just the arrow
of it will
make you like circle around the true
optimal oh yeah
did you compare this to
more just gradient descent like mbo
where you do like a diffusion and
projection step
instead of doing like uh
constrained optimization on the manifold
along the geodesics you can also do like
diffusion and the ambient space and then
project
um
so this is our comparison to um
optimization algorithms that like really
run on the metaphor but um yeah it would
be
interesting to to look into some of
these other
methods as well we also this comparison
doesn't include any uh comparison to
euclidean methods for instance
right so even though that's a non-convex
problem in the euclidean case you could
use
uh euclidean methods um
and compare against those so this is
really just a comparison to reminding
optimization algorithms but yeah that'd
be interesting to see
could you show again this uh this result
where
this theoretical result where you
solve the optimization problem up to a
fraction and then you still got
convergence
what what is m of theta oh
yeah i should have mentioned that so
that's that's called the the curvature
constant
and so that's like a sort of a
hyperparameter that would depend on your
objective function
um
so for instance yeah so it has to do
with like the the lipschitz comes the
smoothness of the function for instance
which which way does it kind of contain
second derivatives or what i mean how is
it defined yeah
in a sense it's um
the the second order
quantifies the second order error in a
sense
okay so because in a sentence you
already did quantify a little bit the
second order by your strict complexity
condition right that is also the
one-sided second order control
yeah and now you're having now this m
contains kind of
also a second order control from the
other side
or i mean how is it actually defined
it's like so so we
um we have it in the paper yeah it has
to do with the the convexity as as you
were saying um and it can also be
bounded with respect to the lipschitz
constant so we have some
just some i'm just summarizing that here
too
um i mean essentially you could write
like
on the order one over k and then have
some constants
coming in that depend on the objective
function which if you summarize with
that
curvature constant and then i'm just
writing that out here to show the the
impact of that data
but yes it can be
much more carefully
defined what exactly the constants are
in the iteration complexity
i'm just wondering because i mean some
of these numerical analysis applications
i know
the the merit is exactly that you get
convergence results which do not depend
on kind of further properties like the
curvature of the underlying space like
higher order derivatives of five that
just rely on strings
being so
but here
that might be in your case hidden in
this constant
so it does not depend on the curvature
of the space
it's certainly yeah so it's independent
of the space but it depends on
um
on the con like under the properties of
the objective function
either theoretically in practice
manifolds with positive curvature
no actually i haven't i've only tried it
on how to match manipulates
and that's negative yeah yeah
yeah so so i mean
most of the results um that i showed
also like the the conversions result and
you know like this and make conversions
results so those would work for any
romanian manifold um but yeah for the
numerical experiments um we mostly focus
like if you look into the paper we
mostly focus on
problems where you can actually solve
the linear oracle efficiently
um and i'm not aware of an example for
positively curved metals yeah
yeah but you could run a numerical
experiment and then just use a
a numerical solver for the separate
humans and try that yeah
but thank you